Regardez cette vache sous la pluie.
C’est une simple vache,
toute mouillée.
Elle est là,
stoïque,
sous la pluie.
Elle n’est pas malheureuse,
cette vache,
ni particulièrement heureuse non plus ;
elle est juste passive
dans la façon qu’elle a de se rapporter
à cette circonstance extérieure,
indépendante
de sa volonté
- la pluie.
Cette vache accepte l’existence comme elle
vient.
Elle n’insulte pas le ciel,
elle n’espère pas le retour du beau temps
;
elle accepte,
c’est tout.
Cette vache sous la pluie
incarne une forme de sagesse.
Je suis Romain,
et vous êtes sur 1000 idées de culture générale.
Cette image d’une vache sous la pluie
elle a été proposée par Tim Ferriss,
l’expert en productivité de la Silicon
Valley,
lors d’une conférence Ted d’avril 2017.
Je vous ai mis le lien dans la description,
si vous voulez la regarder.
Dans cette conférence,
Tim Ferriss utilise l’image de la vache
sous la pluie
pour prêcher le stoïcisme,
une philosophie de la Grèce antique,
vieille de de vingt-cinq siècles,
aux geeks de la Silicon Valley.
Plutôt étonnant, non ?
Il leur définit le stoïcisme dans leur langue,
comme un « système de productivité »,
un « outil »
pour atteindre ses objectifs
dans l’environnement très incertain de
l’entrepreneuriat
- tout particulièrement à l’heure d’internet
et de la disruption permanente.
À le croire,
l’entrepreneur,
et plus généralement l’homme hyperactif
du XXIème siècle,
devrait prendre exemple
sur la vache sous la pluie.
Ses difficultés,
le poids de ses efforts,
et la souffrance
ne sont pas une fatalité.
Le remède est ancien.
Retour donc
vingt-cinq siècles en arrière.
J’ai décidé,
pour approfondir ma compréhension du stoïcisme,
et ainsi peut-être mieux l'appliquer au quotidien,
de synthétiser entièrement ce volume de
la Pléïade,
intitulé « Les Stoïciens ».
C’est une compilation de textes
traduits par l’historien de la philosophie
Émile Bréhier,
sous la direction du philosophe Pierre-Maxime
Schuhl.
Cette vidéo est donc une introduction générale
au stoïcisme,
parce que j’ai l’intention,
dans les prochains mois,
de faire, au fur et à mesure,
d’autres vidéos
sur tous les autres textes du volume.
J’ai principalement utilisé mes notes sur
les préfaces
pour faire celle-ci.
Allez,
je rentre dans le vif du sujet :
on est en Grèce antique,
dans la seconde moitié du quatrième siècle
avant J.-C.
À l’origine du stoïcisme,
il y a un homme :
Zénon de Citium,
à ne pas confrondre avec Zénon d’Élée,
un philosophe présocratique
qui sévissait deux siècle plus tôt.
Citium c’est une ville de Chypre,
où Zénon vivait dans une riche famille de
commerçants.
À vingt et un ans,
il part étudier la philosophie à Athènes,
un peu comme les provinciaux montent à Paris.
Comme il était un demi-barbare,
il parlait un Grec pas terrible,
il s’exprimait surtout par sentences,
ce qui contrastait fortement
avec l’éloquence cultivée dans les écoles
philosophiques.
Ce handicap de départ est d'ailleurs peut-être
la source
de l’art stoïcien des conseils moraux,
qui s’appelle la « parénétique ».
Alors,
le parcours de Zénon est bien sûr crucial
dans l’émergence du stoïcisme,
mais il faut reconnaître aussi
que les circonstances étaient favorables.
Les esprits étaient mûrs pour cette nouvelle
philosophie.
Tout d’abord,
les conflits de succession après la mort
d’Alexandre le Grand
avaient nourri une certaine déception à
l’égard de la politique.
Sur le plan spirituel, ensuite,
les Grecs craignaient de moins en moins les
dieux ;
mais les idées de Platon et d’Aristote
leur semblaient inutilement compliquées,
et inversement,
ils trouvaient les sagesses pratiques
trop superficielles.
Enfin,
il y avait bien la nouvelle école d’Épicure
qui jouissait d'un certain succès,
mais tout le monde ne s’y reconnaissait
pas
- beaucoup de Grecs recherchaient un autre
idéal.
Ce sont ces hommes qui vont se grouper autour
de Zénon.
Épicure installe son école à Athènes
dans son fameux jardin
en 306 avant J.-C.,
puis Zénon vient lui donner la réplique
en 301,
sous un portique de l’Agora
la fameuse place sociale de la cité,
- c’est pour ça que son école s’appelle
« l’école du portique ».
Portique c’est « stoa » en grec ancien
- c’est là l’origine du mot « stoïcisme
».
Je l’ai dit,
les esprits étaient particulièrement mûrs
pour cette nouvelle sagesse,
mais le succès de l’école doit beaucoup
à la personnalité de son fondateur.
Zénon menait en effet une vie qu’il voulait
exemplaire,
sur le plan moral :
les passions étaient à ses yeux de vraies
maladies ;
il s’habillait toujours de la même manière,
il mangeait simplement,
parlait peu,
et il était facile à vivre.
Cette austérité légendaire le rendait très
populaire,
au point qu’il a reçu des honneurs publics
à plusieurs reprises.
Le problème,
en revanche,
c’est que c’était difficile, pour les
disciples,
d’imiter une morale aussi sévère.
Quand la philosophie stoïcienne était encore
toute nouvelle,
elle vivait forcément une période de vie
originale,
et les adeptes étaient enthousiastes.
Mais la ferveur initiale de ce premier stoïcisme
des fondateurs,
appelé « ancien stoïcisme »,
cette ferveur est naturellement retombée
au bout d’un moment.
À tel point que la doctrine de Zénon est
devenue
un genre de catéchisme,
que les élèves apprennent par coeur
et récitent devant leurs parents.
L’école a même connu des défections
- un peu comme dans les partis politiques
-
voire des trahisons,
comme celle du tyran obèse Denys d’Héraclée,
qui fut d’abord l’élève de Zénon,
avant de se convertir à l’épicurisme.
Bref, c’était un peu la crise.
Ça l’était d’autant plus que,
sur le plan des idées,
le stoïcisme n’était plus en phase avec
les mentalités.
On est de la fin du deuxième au premier siècle
avant J.-C.,
à Rome,
où le stoïcisme a été importé avec le
reste de la civilisation grecque.
La philosophie stoïcienne rencontre trois
obstacles majeurs :
tout d’abord,
les Romains demandent des préceptes moraux,
des phrases simples et claires
qui énoncent des règles pour une vie meilleure
- or l’ancien stoïcisme s’était borné
à poser les principes théoriques de la morale
;
ensuite,
les Romains se remettent à la religion,
alors que l’ancien stoïcisme n’a pas
grand chose à faire
de l’au-delà et de la vie après la mort
;
troisième obstacle,
les Romains sont de plus en plus épris de
sciences
dont les explications font de l’ombre
à la vision du monde stoïcienne.
Avec ces trois obstacles,
c’était un peu un moment darwinien pour
le stoïcisme :
il lui a fallu s’adapter pour survivre.
La renaissance a été principalement l’oeuvre
de deux hommes,
Panétios,
puis son disciple Posidonios,
les deux figures principales
de ce qu’on nomme le « moyen » stoïcisme.
Que retenir de cette renaissance ?
Le « moyen » stoïcisme est le résultat
de l’influence d’autres courants.
Panétios,
qui est parfois présenté
comme la toute première source de l’humanisme
occidental,
ce Panétios a fait évoluer la doctrine
vers une morale plus pratique,
en s’inspirant du cynisme, par exemple.
Son disciple,
Posidonios,
qui était le prof de Cicéron,
a pour sa part rapproché le stoïcisme
de la religion et de la science.
C’est donc grâce à ces deux réformateurs,
que la philosophie de Zénon
a survécu en s’adaptant à l’esprit des
temps nouveaux.
Il faut aussi leur reconnaître de l’avoir
simplifiée,
de l’avoir allégée de pas mal de détails
dogmatiques,
ce qui a permis d’en faire un peu
le mode d’emploi d’une pratique morale
de plus en plus répandue,
ce qu’on appelle aujourd'hui l’examen
de conscience.
Le stoïcisme s’est ensuite propagé
dans différentes couches de la société
romaine
essentiellement grâce à Cicéron.
Le courant a été un foyer de résistance
aux despotismes des empereurs,
notamment Néron.
C’était alors une école de pensée indépendante,
où on refusait de se soumettre
aux cultes imposés par le pouvoir.
Par exemple,
le sénateur stoïcien Thraseas,
dont la vie exemplaire faisait passer Néron
pour un débauché,
s’est ouvert les veines en 66
pour offrir son sang à Jupiter.
Cette résistance passive a heureusement pris
fin
avec les empereurs suivants
– Hadrien, Antonin, et bien sûr Marc-Aurèle
–
qui étaient, eux,
favorables au stoïcisme.
Là
on sort des grandes époques stoïciennes,
donc j’appuie sur le champignon.
Le stoïcisme a eu une influence continue,
plus ou moins implicite,
au cours des siècles suivants.
Il a un peu imprégné les premières théologies
chrétiennes,
même si elles n’étaient pas matérialistes.
Son influence s’est faite plus explicite
à la Renaissance,
où on le retrouve par exemple dans l’introspection
que mène Montaigne dans ses Essais.
À l’époque classique,
Descartes s’en inspire de manière évidente
- sa maxime « Changer ses désirs plutôt
que l’ordre du monde.
»
aurait pu sortir de la bouche de Zénon.
Et ce ne sont que quelques exemples,
parmi les plus avérés.
D’après Émile Bréhier,
on peut voir dans l’inspiration stoïcienne
un facteur constant
de l’histoire de la philosophie
comme de la littérature.
Et le stoïcisme est même recyclé aujourd’hui
par les stars américaines du développement
personnel
comme Tim Ferriss.
Mais l’historien de la philosophie,
qui est mort en 1952,
nous avait prévenus dans sa préface :
les hommes auront toujours à apprendre
de la sagesse stoïcienne.
Aux États-Unis,
les universitaires spécialistes du stoïcisme
ne voient pas d’un très bon oeil
l’actuelle renaissance de leur philosophie
préférée.
Ils rappellent,
entre autres griefs,
que le stoïcisme ne se résume pas à des
compilations de slogans,
comme « Memento mori »
- slogan qui n’est d’ailleurs pas spécifiquement
stoïcien,
à l’origine.
C’est vrai que le stoïcisme constituait
au départ
un système complet et cohérent,
avec au centre une conception du monde physique,
et autour, notamment,
des conceptions de la logique, de la dialectique,
et de la rhétorique.
La fameuse morale stoïcienne
n’était que le couronnement de ce sytème.
Pour autant,
les spécialistes ne peuvent pas nier
qu’elle en était aussi la partie essentielle.
C’est pour ça, je trouve,
que les discours des oracles de l’entrepreneuriat
comme Tim Ferriss,
sont en réalité plutôt fidèles
à l’esprit originel du stoïcisme.
D’ailleurs,
l’école stoïcienne fournissait des précepteurs
moraux,
qui devenaient parfois ensuite les conseillers
politiques
de leurs prestigieux élèves.
Et puis après tout,
comme l’a bien rappelé Pierre Hadot
dans Qu’est-ce que la philosophie antique
?,
la doctrine stoïcienne était surtout,
comme toute philosophie antique,
la prescription d’un certain mode de vie.
Bon,
je referme la parenthèse,
et j’en viens aux idées
- c’est un peu le nom de la chaîne.
Alors,
quelle est cette fameuse morale stoïcienne
?
Son fondement est plutôt simple :
l’individu doit conformer ses désirs et
ses actions
à l’ordre,
rationnel et divin,
de la nature.
Il faut en d’autres termes,
selon Épictète,
« vouloir que les choses arrivent comme elles
arrivent ».
À l’instar de la vache qui endure passivement
la pluie,
le parfait stoïcien pratique le détachement
:
il néglige les facteurs extérieurs
qui ne dépendent pas de lui,
et il évite ainsi de créer lui-même
sa propre souffrance.
On peut prendre des exemples concrets pour
mieux comprendre :
à quoi bon se lamenter de la météo ?
à quoi bon espérer le bon temps ?
à quoi bon s’énerver dans les bouchons
?
est-ce que ça va débloquer la circulation
à quoi bon, pour un élève,
déprimer à propos de ses notes passées
?
à quoi bon, pour un entrepreneur,
se laisser abattre par un obstacle inattendu
?
La clef de la sagesse pratique stoïcienne,
c’est que l’on souffre souvent inutilement
en imagination
- le remède,
c’est simplement d’accepter ce qui est,
et de passer à autre chose.
« Souviens-toi, écrit Épictète,
que tu es comme un acteur dans le rôle que
l’auteur t’a confié :
il dépend de toi de bien jouer ton rôle,
mais non de le choisir.
»
J’aime encore mieux l’image stoïcienne
du chien qui suit le mouvement de la charrette
à laquelle il est attaché.
À quoi bon s’épuiser à résister ?
Autant épouser le mouvement.
J’ai l’impression que les animaux
sont bien plus stoïciens que nous.
Et en effet,
l’érudition, le raffinement de la connaissance
sont inutiles ;
la seule chose qui compte,
c’est la certitude intérieure
tirée de l’accord intime
à l’ordre des choses.
Dans la morale matérialiste et sensualiste
des stoïciens,
il n’y a pas de dilemme
entre la liberté et le déterminisme.
Il faut simplement endurer l’existence,
de la même manière que la vache endure la
pluie.
Avec un calme stoïque.
Le stoïcisme est une philosophie particulièrement
intéressante
parce qu’il repose sur des préceptes simples
pour améliorer l’existence.
Sa longévité exceptionnelle,
de Zénon à Tim Ferriss,
s’explique probablement par cette utilité
pratique,
mais aussi, surtout,
par la souplesse de la doctrine.
Son message principal,
encore une fois,
c’est que l’homme est lui-même
la cause principale de son malheur,
de telle sorte qu’il est en son pouvoir,
par le détachement à l’égard
de ce qui ne dépend pas de lui,
d’être moins malheureux,
ou plus heureux si on veut.
Pour conclure,
je dois admettre que je suis moi-même
un peu fan de cette philosophie :
son diagnostic me semble évidemment juste
;
elle est simple, claire,
et puis elle ne coûte rien.
Il faut juste faire l’effort
- certes quotidien,
renouvelé,
permanent -
il faut faire l'effort
de nettoyer son esprit
de toutes ses inquiétudes inutiles.
N’est-ce pas qu’elle est sage,
la vache sous la pluie ?
Si vous avez aimé la vidéo,
mettez un pouce bleu et abonnez-vous à la
chaîne
pour être prévenu de la sortie de la suivante.
Pour lire l’article de blog tiré de ma
lecture,
voire pour vous attaquer à ce volume de la
Pléïade,
tous les liens sont dans la description.
N’hésitez pas non plus à laisser des commentaires.
Pour recevoir les dernières idées de culture
générale
synthétisées dans le format le plus clair
possible,
vous pouvez vous inscrire à la newsletter
en laissant votre adresse e-mail sur le site.
Je suis Romain
et sous étiez sur 1000 idées de culture
générale.
Soyez stoïcien :
vous n’avez pas besoin de vous prendre la
tête
pour vous intéresser au meilleur de la pensée.